jeudi soir voilà casimir qui à rire
il m'a l'air bien agitée il doit avoir
une bonne nouvelle à nous annoncer
parce que quand ça va mal il est très
discret bonjour tous les deux
aujourd'hui quasi vie j'ai vous savez
pas quoi il parle nouvelle à nous
annoncer ça alors mais comment avez vous
deviné
tu sais tu as du mal à faire des
surprises quand il est vraiment content
c'est vrai oui chaque fois je me dis il
faut que je prenne un air triste à l'est
plus j'approche desjardins plus j'ai
envie de courir et de danser je crois
que tous nos amis comprennent ça très
bien
il leur arrive exactement la même chose
à chaque fois qu'ils veulent faire une
bonne surprise à leur maman ou leur tata
pour une personne qu'ils aiment beaucoup
est-ce pas c'est vraiment je suis bien
content de ne pas être le sol et après
tout quelle est cette bonne idée
vous connaissez monsieur beauchemin sur
le marchand de meubles de l'île aux
enfants c'est ça il est même très gentil
et bien il m'a offert le mode que je
voulais pour ma maison ici fantastique
yockey l'honneur pas ce que je l'ait
aidée à déménager tous au hangar de
meubles tous les mains noires et allons
sommes très fiers de toi mais tu dois
être très fatigué croit tellement
pourtant casimir les meubles sont des
choses très lourde
c'est vrai tu sais qu'on soit que
casimir est devenu très fort depuis les
faits les exercices de danse
casimir
quel est le meuble le plus lourd que tu
es transporter sa aucun comment kg paris
judiciaire je l'expliqué
casimir veut dire qu'il ne transportait
aucun meuble très lourd parce que
monsieur beauchesne ne lui a confié que
des petits meubles très léger tu n'as
rien compris du tout françois comme
d'habitude merci quand même
écoute c simple même si jaunards et
transporter que les morgues le léger il
aurait bien le parmi eux amable plus
lourd que les autres c'est vrai bon
alors ma réponse était claire si je t'ai
répondu aucun c'est quand j'aurai
transporté au câble alors c'est moi qui
ne comprend plus rien du tout maintenant
noyer longtemps que j'ai abandonné
casimir bras c'est moi ben oui je sais
est ce que tu peux m'expliquer quelque
chose
comment as tu pu déménager avec mathieu
beauchesne les meubles de son hangar
sans emporter ou qu'un set au oui c'est
tout c'est très sage je me suis assis
dans un grand fauteuil très confortable
et chaque fois que monsieur beauchesne
passé avec un gros match je
l'encourageais en criant oh oui oh nice
ou bien alors je lui disais pratiquement
chaîne rasy beauchesne vas-y alors ça
l'a beaucoup amusée hillary le temps est
passé très vite pour lui et en
récompense il m'a offert le meuble que
je voulais je reconnais que nous étions
bien loin de force s est elle même lundi
the viable c'est là mon problème je ne
sais pas quel meuble choisir d aimer les
enfants vont certainement nous aider à
choisir le meuble dont il a besoin pour
ta maison
ah oui c'est vrai ça françois il
ils ont toujours des idées
extraordinaires puis ça va être un jeu
très amusant les enfants
tenez bon tenez vite l'affairé jeu
on va essayer cd casimir a trouvé un
meuble pour sa maison
vous êtes d'accord en faire un jeu alors
vous allez me donner le plus grand
nombre possible de meubles et après
casimir fera son choix
julie est une autre mes meubles oui
certes en quelqu'un premiers meubles
charm une cuisinière une cuisinière un
meuble de cuisine
eliane y croyaient indispensables ça
jamais eu un cas une réponse à noël
buffet nach unique
bon j'ai pas de baisser une machine à
laver ça c'est encore pour la cuisine
il prédit une table de nuit pour barak
dont émilie gamelin jean charles une
tape la salle à manger moins jean
nicloux des charges et des assiettes ça
ça c'est la vaisselle pour mettre un
canapé eliane mais les achète on lui
avait parlé on les mettra dans nom
george buffet qui donne un effet quasi
muet
je crois que j'ai de quoi choisir l'a
écouté mes amis je vous remercie vous
m'avez vraiment donner des idées
extraordinaires quelque chose attendez
je vais aller chercher mon mal et je
leur amènerait pour vous le montrez
raconte attention tout à l'heure
[Musique]
voilà comme ça je vais pouvoir me
regarder
ah oui comme ça je suis vraiment gros
pas comme ça je suis plutôt comique ça
c'est pas mal par là c'est bien ça
casini intra qu'est ce que ça fait c'est
moi je te croyais parti pour chercher un
meuble ah oui ça y est je suis déjà
revenu oui regarde mon meuble ce miroir
ouais il est beau et bien sûr casimir
mais que vas tu faire danser grand
miroir je vais me regarder
j'adore me regarder dans un miroir pour
voir quelles sont mes positions les plus
comiques ou alors comment je suis le
plus beau quasi muet que ce prénom
ridicule
il faut pas se préoccuper sans cesse de
sa propre personne
outre son physique mais alors à quoi
sert un miroir si on ne peut pas se
regarder dedans ne s'agit pas de ne
jamais se regarder dans une glace par
exemple ça sert le matin pour vérifier
si on est bien coiffée bah oui mais moi
j'ai pas de cheveux si on sait bien
laver les dents à mais tu sais bien que
je n'aie pas dedans bon et si on à la
figure propres tu ne vas pas me dire que
d'une à fatiguer ah oui c'est une figure
est justement
j'adore regarder ma figure très
longtemps que l'on me voir et faire des
tas de grimaces drôle est que casimir
casimir j'ai trop qu'aucun des personnes
âgées comme ça tu n'imagines pas gély
passons des heures devant sa glace en
train de faire des grimaces
iman monsieur du snob et entend mal
d'acteurs et je suis même certain
cl tu avais vu il tend à être tous
trouvé vraiment ridicule prends toi
non tu n'as pas à discuter non non je ne
discute pas je voudrais seulement que
qui viennent voir quelque chose quoi
encore mais il était parfait minable
métairie snob jaguar là juste là
derrière toi qui disais tout à l'heure à
propos de julie monsieur du snob et le
facteur rien je crois bien que je n'aie
rien ah bon c'est bien ce qu'il me
semblait aussi juillet un monsieur du
chemin neuf facteurs
attendez moi je venais les grimaces et
de nantes
regardez
[Musique]